from the guy who ruined two franchises
comes resident evil afterlife right off
the bat in the first 10 minutes of this
movie you see that this movie is the
poster child for a movie ticket refund
horrible stunts physics people flipping
up and around and then twirling around
in the air noticeably on wires and then
you realize that if you see this movie
not as an installment to the Resident
Evil franchise but as a prequel to
ultraviolet it makes a little more sense
this is horrible but it makes more sense
and then the movie shows us that a
normal woman can survive a plane crash
when it crashes head-on into a mountain
so good news the Big Bopper Buddy Holly
and Ritchie Valens will all be coming
out with her new album next week and you
know what I noticed about these Resident
Evil movies is that they have the most
iconic characters and survival horror
video games played by the most generic
actors of all time I mean the movies
aren't even Resident Evil at this point
it's like a great be zombie movie that
happens to have a few characters from a
video game franchise just thrown in
there they might as well throw in the
octoroks by now this is no more Resident
Evil than that Mario movie was a Super
Mario Brothers movie mm-hmm and Wesker's
in this movie played by a 26 year old
because when I think Captain Wesker I
think 26 year old gap employee and he
talks like this like he got his jaw
wired shut while he was taking acting
lessons from Agent Smith and this movie
is just boring I mean it's just nothing
really happens in this movie I mean a
standard zombie movie protocol you have
a bunch of people in a facility and
they're trapped inside and there are
zombies outside and then zombies get in
and then they need to get outside but
then you have shitty impossible physics
that would kill anybody in real life
example you have a bunch of people in an
elevator and you have no power but it's
okay because you can just through a bomb
on the roof of the elevator and when it
detonates it'll snap the cable and the
elevator will freefall 20 stories and
land safely in water I mean if the bomb
doesn't turn your friends into hamburger
the sudden impact after the freefall
will but in this movie they're all fine
stupid and this movie's plagued with
moments that just turn into slow-motion
for no apparent reason like in the
Matrix Reloaded it's almost like they do
it just to draw out the runtime of this
movie without the slow-mo shots the
movie probably be a solid hour long and
they boasted in the trailers that these
are the same cameras that filmed avatar
like that means something that's like me
having a paintbrush and going this is
the same paintbrush that Boris Vallejo
you
that means I can do what he does I mean
like you're magically downloaded with
the knowledge as to how to use it well
so if you want you can film a film with
James Cameron's cameras but in the end
you're still the guy who brought us a VP
I mean the characters are Hollow the
plot is tired the action is crap with
impossible physics and noticeably shitty
wire tricks I can sincerely say Paul WS
Anderson I'm really glad that you did
not get the green light to rape
Castlevania but in the end I'd buy this
movie even on blu-ray if I like dark
[ __ ] so if you need your zombie fix go
rent done of the dead or play the
Resident Evil games much better but if
you like what you've seen here and you
want to see more than click right here
to see more